salut parmi les quatorze mille demandes
de brevets déposées à l'inpi en 2020 se
cachent des idées vues par les moins
huit morts des mois de travail acharné
tandis que pour d'autres idées leur
invention révolutionnaire au niveau
mondial viennent d'un pur hasard ça
porte un nom c'est ce qu'on appelle la
sérendipité
alors comment ont été découverts les
effets du viagra intéressant comment
alfred nobel at il inventé le vinaigre
intéressant comme un appareil destiné à
enregistrer le rythme cardiaque s'est
finalement retrouvée dans le corps de
plus de 4 millions de personnes par des
vaccins contre un virus non je déconne
en tout cas c'est ce que vous allez
découvrir entre autres dans cette vidéo
loïc via côté de moi fabricants
génériques ici là devant tout le monde
on veut te voir fabrique un général
[Musique]
au début des années 90 le laboratoire
pfizer à l'époque que vous en foutiez de
ce nombre il est très connu travaille
sur un médicament qui permettrait de
soigner des angines de poitrine
pfizer s'oriente vers le citrate de
sildénafil et les essais cliniques
démarre très très mal le médicament ne
fonctionne pas gros effets secondaires
étrange un peu jamais vu des patients
qui ont des érections qui durent pendant
plusieurs jours les 10 ans du coup on
met ça dans la notice effet secondaire
fréquent grosse érection en 1993 pfizer
réoriente alors ses recherches vers
l'impuissance masculine qui touche un
tiers des hommes de plus de 40 ans c'est
déjà beaucoup et jusqu'à cette période
des solutions qui permettent de contrer
l'impuissance sont quand même vachement
moins de l'amour ces mini suppositoire
qu'on s'est introduit dans l'urètre
directement voilà où des piqûres
directement dans le pénis et le 27 mars
1990 et de l'agencé américaine du
médicament donne son accord et en deux
semaines ce sont pas moins de 150 mille
prescription qui sont alors délivré le
viagra de via une source de revenus
inespéré pour fighter qui sort des
milliards de piles is de ses usines et
voit entrer des milliards de dollars
dans ses caisses cependant petite
annotation le viagra a fait le bonheur
de millions d'hommes mais a laissé sur
le banc de touche des millions de femmes
qui n'ont aujourd'hui toujours aucun
remède correct pour contrer par exemple
le manque de libido
donc ce serait bien aussi de s'y
intéresser 2 le bâton de dynamite en
1859 emmanuel nobel un ingénieur et
savants suédois décide avec al presse
son fils de 26 ans de travailler sur un
explosif à base de nitroglycérine un
matériau qui au moindre choc explique
pas facile quoi alfred met alors au
point un système d'allumage
mais le matériau est très instable et
les accidents se multiplient
il se mutile plus tellement que les
usines des nobel explose littéralement
1864 emile l'un des deux frères d'alfred
meurt dans l'explosion trois ans plus
tard 1867 alfred croit voir venir son
tour il fait tomber de la nitro aux
seuls à ses pieds mais la surprise la
nuit tron n'expose pas aller en fait
tomber sur du g7 dur je crois que ça se
dit comme ça c'est une paire siliceux ce
port heureuse qui est utilisé en
laboratoire et qu'il a absorbé et le
mélange est toujours aussi explosif mais
beaucoup plus stable et donc plus sûr à
manipuler et alfred découvre alors en
faisant des petits et c'est qu'avec 25 %
de qui est cette cure la nitro
devient stable et peut être conditionnés
sous forme de tube en carton et de
déclencher de plus loin il ya un
détonateur dont qu'il appellera ça de la
dynamite et c'est trois fois plus
puissant que la poudre et ça devient le
premier empire industriel planétaire
quelques années plus tard alfred est
surnommé le marchand de la mort mais
cette appellation le marchand de la mort
ça lui plaît pas trop et comme celle-là
blessé il a créé une institution qui
récompensera chaque année cinq personnes
qui ont rendu de grands services à
l'humanité qu'est ce que tu as rendu
qu'en grand service à l'humanité par
exemple toile loïc cette année ouais
ouais
peut-être tu auras le prix de ça c'est
vrai en tout cas ça s'appelle la
fondation nobel à laquelle il léguera
d'ailleurs la quasi totalité de son
immense fortune
3 le pays en 1949 le canadien john oxx
commence à travailler sur l'hypothermie
qui permet à cette époque d'opérer à
coeur ouvert sept petits soucis dans ce
genre d'intervention c'est que si le
coeur du patient s'arrête
bessane donc c'est pas très rassurant du
coup de faire cette opération aube se
découvre alors qu'il est possible de
relancer un coeur grâce à une
stimulation électrique et en 1951 il
développe le premier appareil au monde
qui envoie une impulsion électrique afin
de stimuler le coeur mais l'appareil pas
très petits parce qu'il a la taille d'un
poste de télévision
donc on décide pas un souci de
simplicité de le laisser en dehors du
corps du coup parce que sinon fallait
enlever les poumons stenger sauf que en
1956 l'américain wilson gré batch
s'intéresse aux troupes de l'activité
cardiaque et décide de construire un
oscillateur qui permettrait
d'enregistrer le rythme cardiaque mais
wilson un peu dé temps l'air ne met pas
le bon transistors de la machine c'est
con parce qu'on parle de mecs quand même
qui touche à notre coeur mais le
résultat est intéressant son appareil
envoie des impulsions électriques
un rythme qui imite celui du coeur il
vient de réinventer le stimulateur
cardiaque de john oxx wilson se referme
alors dans sa grange pendant plus de
deux ans prison ferme toujours dans des
granges d'ailleurs pour construire des
trucs et ils fabriquent 50 exemplaires
miniaturisés de son pacemaker en 1960 le
stimulateur de wilson sera implanté chez
un patient pour la première fois du
monde et chaque année en france
maintenant ce sont pas moins de soixante
mille personnes qui se sont implantés
cette invention a permis de prolonger la
vie de millions et de millions de
personnes dont celle de son inventeur
john oxx et dans un instant vous allez
voir que la matière que vous connaissez
le plus il n'avait jamais prévu
d'exister de notre libido au plaisir
d'éclater les petites
de plastique entre nos doigts comme on
le verra tout à l'heure les inventions
qui ont été créés par sérendipité sont
extrêmement nombreuses et touchent tous
les domaines c'est un peu fou quand on
commence à chercher là dessus que vous
n'êtes pas au bout de vos surprises
parce qu'il ya des hasards comme ça qui
en lui en permanence d'ailleurs est ce
que vous saviez ça c'est par hasard que
dans le prochain numéro de curieuses mon
magazine vous allez pouvoir justement
lire un dossier entier sur la
sérendipité et notamment découvrir qu'en
mélangeant de l'ue rina du sable vous
pouviez fabriquer du phosphore c'est
quand même fou en tout cas vous avez le
lien vers mon magazine dans la
description
c'est un magazine qui sort dix fois par
an c'est un presque mensuel et pour
l'abonnement ses 29 90 par an ou 19 90
au format numérique par an j'ai bien dit
par an pour recevoir 52 pages dans vos
boîtes aux lettres parce que les frais
de port sont inclus je vous mets le lien
je voulais dit dans la description ça
vous emmène sur le site où vous verrez
aussi des anciens numéros déjà paru il
ya déjà une année complète de paris
et puis vous pourrez lire des articles
gratuitement pour voir si ça vous plaît
ou pas mais abonnez vous qu'est ce que
vous attendez la curiosité dans ta boîte
aux lettres classiques en 1869 la
société américaine fait l'âne corner
lors d'un concours
elle promet deal et le dollar à la
personne qui réussira à trouver une
matière capable de remplacer l'ivoire
des éléphants qui étaient utilisés à
l'époque dans la production de boules de
billards que la société fabrique l'idée
principale c'est de contrer la pénurie
de matières premières même pas de sauver
des éléphants à celui ci l'ont pas assez
d'ivoire en feu
par conséquent ça va protéger les
éléphants ce qui nous fait rire un peu
jaune aujourd'hui face au million et
demi d'animaux qui meurent chaque année
victimes des déchets plastiques là parce
que du coup on a inventé le plastique
pour un peu sauver les éléphants mais
maintenant les animaux meurent à cause
des plastiques
bref john wesley il y atteint new york
et participe au concours est en tout cas
primeur pour se protéger les doigts il
utilise de la nitrocellulose qui dissout
dans l'alcool
et quand le sol devant s'évapore ça
laisse derrière lui une petite pellicule
plastique transparent imperméable à
l'encré la matière est trop flexible
pour en faire des boules de billard mais
après plusieurs essais john finit par la
mélanger and qu'en france il ya un
composé naturel est là
il obtient alors une substance flexible
solide et modelabs sous l'effet de la
chaleur qu'il appelle celluloïd
alors ensuite son utilisation ira bien
au delà des boules de billard puisque on
fabriquera avec des clips et des
pellicules de cinéma ou même encore les
premières dents artificielles le seul
problème c'est que la matière est
extrêmement inflammable et il n'était
pas rare d'obtenir une explosion quand
deux boules de billards seront complets
sur le tapis sera explosif
c'est d'ailleurs la principale raison
qui fait qu'on n'utilise quasiment plus
de nos jours ça aujourd'hui les balles
de ping-pong sont encore par contre
fabriqué en celluloïd attention pendant
la prochaine partie gouffre est le fond
à micro-ondes 1945 l'américain persie
spencer est ingénieur chez sociétés
spécialisées dans la défense
l'électronique et l'aérospatiale et doit
perfectionner le magnétron j'ai vraiment
l'impression d'être dans un bunker
zurich y avec moi allons perfectionner
le magnétron le magnétron c'est un
dispositif capable de produire des ondes
ultra courtes des micro ondes pour les
radars anti aériens et un jours merci
prend une pause pendant une expérience
sur un nouveau type de magnétron met la
main dans sa poche
il sort une barre chocolatée qui est
chaude et fondue et la paire 6 dit
bizarre du coup ils veulent un placard
il prend du maïs il approche du micro
ondes et parts du groupe korn dis pas
qu'on s'a du coup il prend 1,9 la proche
de micro ondes et pape diop l'explosif
est pas con ça du coup il prend le chien
il a bien je décode pensser en conclut
que les micro ondes ont provoqué
l'agitation des molécules d'eau
présentes dans les aliments et que ce
phénomène les a fait cuire chauffer en
fait en réalité en 1946 rayton dépose un
brevet en 1947 sort le premier modèle du
micro imposant un peu un mètre 82 au
pour 340 kg le tout pour 3500 $ 1 m 82
euros et à dire moi je fais deux mètres
à peu près comme ça allait là quand je
fais de mettre dix semaines échelle pour
démarrer lusage du micro et donc réservé
aux professionnels de la restauration
ceux des hôpitaux et autres compagnies
de vagues gullit l2
les wagons lits des trains les premiers
modèles de mikron grand public seront
commercialisés vingt ans plus tard
aujourd'hui plus de deux millions et
demi de micro ondes sont vendus en
france chaque année et les dans le top
10 des objets dans les français ne
peuvent pas se passer d'un ménage qui
paralyse et fois micro-ondes le papier
bulle 1957 l'américain alfred filing et
le suisse marc chavannes ont une idée
qui va révolutionner votre intérieur
créer un papier peint en plastique et en
relief ont redémarré et commence à
prendre de rideau de douche qu'il passe
dans une machine de thermo rétraction
afin de laisser les ensembles le
résultat est alors très mauvais le mec
il on t'a fait des semaines et des
semaines il connaît de truies une
machine qui a un nom imprononçable et à
la fin ils font c'est un de la merde
notre truc là du coup le papier pas et
couvert de petites bulles partout et le
binôme garde tout de même le résultat
dans un coin de leur tête et le nomme rk
on a inventé le world cup c'est parce
que jacques les plus tard ça deviendra
le roi le en français ils le proposent
alors comme isolant dans des serres mais
personne n'en veut vraiment et 6 mais
pourquoi faire jusqu'au jour où marc
fait un voyage dans un avion et en
observant comment les nuages semblent
amortir l'avion ni d'élus vient et si le
bug devenait un emballage de protection
pour les avions non pour juste l'école
alfred va les guider et si bon ben si ça
peut nous servir à quelque chose
nos rideaux en plastique on en a
commandé quatre mille donc bon il avait
d'ailleurs le procédé de fabrication
afin d'obtenir un film plastique avec
des bus parfaitement étanche et un peu
plus régulière trois ans plus tard de la
société ibm cherche à protéger son
nouveau système informatique rapport au
papier bulle
ainsi c'est pour le transport jusqu'aux
clients et elle choisit le papier bulle
c'est quand même fou depuis celle d' air
qui possède la marque déposée bird
produit assez de papier à bulle chaque
année pour faire 10 fois le tour de la
terre plus étonnant encore qui se serait
douté de l'addiction à laquelle doivent
faire face de nombreuses personnes
étaient les bulletins on ne peut tous
même sa tête et les bus de tempo si vous
aimez péter les bulles dit j'aime prêter
les bulles dans les commentaires il
existe évidemment plein d'autres
inventions qui ont été créés par hasard
le velcro le stéthoscope encore là à la
radiographie qui a été inventé par
william conrad
guen qui reçu d'ailleurs le premier prix
nobel de physique en 1901 pour sa
découverte vous invite à lire le
prochain curieuse qui comportera un
dossier du coup sûr la sérendipité et
qui vous en dira beaucoup plus sur le
sujet en plus des 45 autres pages sur
tous les sujets moi je m'appelle
toujours fabian lui car n'oubliez pas de
vous abonner à cette chaîne activer la
cloche pour pas rater la prochaine vidéo
leakée cette vidéo si elle vous a plus
passé me voir sur instagram en vous
évitera de me poser des questions dans
les commentaires de trucs dont je parle
déjà sur instagram passé sur instagram
de loïc parce que sinon il me saoule à
venir et 250 millions de personnes sur
place
passez vous abonner à la chaîne
secondaire ont fait des blocs tous les
quinze jours des vidéos en plus vous
avez pas vu sa passe et voir ma mère de
temps en temps un petit sourire ça fait
plaisir un petit bouquet de fleurs
passer de bonnes vacances si jamais vous
êtes en vacances parce qu'on mais il ya
tellement de genres variés que c'est un
petit peu les vacances ici je vous mets
deux vidéos sur six choses sur autre
chose et si chaud sur cette chose là a
dit attendez pas à ça prenez soin de
vous ouais j'étais un peu celui
d'aujourd'hui
excusez moi pardon bisous cha